okay yesterday I told you about this
book which claims that Donald Trump is a
Mafia owned Russian asset the book is
called
house of Trump house of Putin the untold
story of Donald Trump and the Russian
mafia it's by investigative journalist
Craig Unger and one claim made in the
book among many is that Unger said to
Newsweek during an interview about the
book that he has a reason to believe
there's a Russian asset in the White
House who Unger believes is an actual
Russian agent but that part is not 100%
clear but at minimum that there is a
Russian asset working at the White House
that is tied to Russian intelligence I
don't know if the story I'm about to
tell you is related to craig angers book
or not it's not clear whether this is
the person that Ganga was thinking about
or talking about but Democrats in the
House of Representatives are now
investigating national security adviser
John Bolton's ties to the same suspected
Russian spy
Maria boo tina who was recently indicted
and this is just a stunning convergence
of multiple angles of the fiasco that is
the trump administration and i'm gonna
do my best to break it down for you
because it's starting to get very
convoluted we've got Part A which is
Craig angers claimed that there's a
Russian asset working at the White House
Part B from a few weeks ago is that
Maria boo Tina was indicted for being an
unregistered foreign agent and for
conspiracy to act she is believed to be
an agent of the Russian government
working in the United States on Russia's
behalf without properly disclosing it we
learned that booty nough got access not
only to high-level executives at the
National Rifle Association which has
been a possible and likely conduit of
Russian money to the Trump campaign boo
Tina also got access to officials at the
Federal Reserve boo Tina got access to
officials at the Treasury Department and
to at least one congressman that we know
about our friend congressman Russia as I
know him
Dana Rohrabacher a Republican from
California what we now have our
Democratic congressman Elijah Cummings
and Stephen Lynch
who want documents from chief of staff
John
Kelly related to whether John Bolton
reported his previous work with this
alleged Russian spy on his security
clearance forms or on other White House
vetting materials it's suspected that
the current national security adviser to
the President of the United States John
Bolton Trump's third NSA by the way is
tied directly to suspected Russian spy
Maria booty nough through a video that
Bolton participated in for a booty 'no
organized gun rights roundtable
promoting gun rights in russia
this actually was reported months ago by
NPR this was in March of 2018 at the
time Bolton wasn't yet the national
security adviser he became national
security adviser in April and the
details reported by NPR did not get as
much attention as they probably should
have and what we now know is that in
2013 John Bolton participated in a
roundtable discussion organized by the
same Maria boo Tina who has been
indicted and what Democrats are asking
for our documents related to whether
Bolton discussed the contacts that he no
doubt had with someone presumably boo
Tina if not others involved in that
group when he was invited and agreed to
participate in this Russian gun rights
thing which by the way how who even gets
involved in advocating for Russian gun
rights I guess the NRA wants it because
it helps them sell more guns for their
clients I don't know but every time you
shake a tree as I saw written on Reddit
yesterday a Russian drops out of it and
I what is the explanation going to be my
guess is if you ask me do I think that
Bolton put anything about the work he
did with this Russian gun rights group
and his contacts potentially with boo
Tina herself on his sf-86 forum my guess
is like Jared Kushner he forgot to
include that on the forum yeah I mean in
response they'll just deny everything
here and I think they can get away with
that especially because even I'm
skeptical about this connection in a way
because John Bolton is a neocon and you
know his words and actions have
exactly been pro-russia throughout the
years sure like he supports regime
change in Syria which of course Putin in
Bashar al-assad are aligned he also said
that the 2016 election meddling was an
act of war and that the u.s. negotiates
with Russia at its peril so I'm gonna
hold out judgement for now well then if
there's no reason to hide these contacts
I'm sure that they are on his sf-86 form
right yeah I'd love to see that I warm
you up I think they're probably not on
there and this is listen this is just
Trump's national security adviser he
mostly gets coffee and makes dinner
reservations for people on Trump staff
this is not like a oh wait a second it's
the National Security Advisor
yeah that's pretty serious so let's get
those records but I don't think anybody
will be surprised if the sf-86 form is
missing any reference to this
organization or to Maria boo Tina or
whoever his contact was and what I want
to remind you of it's now gonna have to
become a daily reminder Pat's furious
with me that I'm doing this but it has
to be a daily reminder
nothing will happen unless Republicans
lose control on November 6 2018 period
let's make it happen let me know on
Twitter what you think about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com slash Pakman this is
something I really believe in better
help gives you access to fully licensed
and experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer I have been talking for years
about the problem around people not
seeking help because of the stigma
around mental health services because of
the cost of mental health services and
all you have to do with better help is
go to better help calm slash Pakman
answer some basic questions you'll be
matched with a therapist that will be
right for you you can change therapists
if you don't think that it's a good fit
it's less expensive than seeing someone
in person you will still get the
professional help and it is unlimited
you can talk to a therapist every day
from home or wherever you are go to
better help calm slash Pakman
it is so easy to sign up and get started
we've put a link in the description if
you're watching on YouTube better help
calm slash PA que ma n if you've been
wanting to talk to somebody but for
whatever reason haven't please go to
better help calm slash PA que ma N